Okay. You Ready? Yup. All right. Let's open the show today. Test, test,
test on a sunny street corner. Okay. In New Jersey. Oh, where are we now?
We are on Washington Street, which is the main thoroughfare in Hoboken.
It's a nice day in Hoboken.
People are out and about after work cause that Sangria.
Where do you guys go here and we're here with a guy. His name is John Horgan.
I'm a science journalist.
He's also a teacher and John is out today with our producer Lulu Miller doing
what he often does,
which is to go up to someone who doesn't know we're doing a survey.
Only take a minute at [inaudible] and ask them this one question as the
question. Will humans ever stopped fighting wars once and for all?
No.
Because of greed and one upsmanship to explain.
John has been asking this question,
will humans ever stop fighting wars for years? Because for him, this question,
it's not just about war. It gets at something really basic.
Do we feel we can change who we are?
[inaudible]
any case.
The first time it popped out of his mouth who was 2003 and a friend had asked
him to give a talk at a church just a few days after the first invasion of Iraq.
And so here I was in this church and I can remember the mood was very somber.
I was determined to try to make people feel that, okay,
this is a setback, but still you've got to believe that peace is possible.
And I tried to list all the reasons
[inaudible]
and as he was making his case and getting worked up,
you looked at the 60 or so people who were there in the audience. He said,
all right, how many of you here believe that war will end someday?
And I think one or two people raised their hands at a 68
and John Thought, wait, is this really who we are?
And so that's actually when I started reading as much as I can about all these
things and dug up some surveys from the 1980s what he found was that about 20
years ago, 80 people were asking this question,
do you think war will ever end taking surveys? Now,
granted they were not the most scientific of surveys,
but what the results seem to indicate is that we used to be optimistic back in
the 80s only one in three thought that war is inevitable.
It is a minority. Yeah. Whereas today, well,
humans ever stop fighting wars once and for all.
If you take that question to the streets of Hoboken as we did, you will find,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
Not Nine out of 10 people say, no,
no, no, never. No, never. No.
Now depressingly, the worst part is that when he asked him the next question,
why do you this?
Invariably he gets something like,
cause I think there a human nature's too for greed and to always want more.
It's just human nature. A lot of people are big,
dumb animals and they're just gonna keep fighting over useless things in our
genes. It's just the way people are.
And I don't think we're ever going to learn. Why do you say that?
I just think that it's too ingrained in our human nature, so,
so,
so, so, so we want to challenge that last statement
too ingrained in our human nature. That one. Okay.
We know some things have been handed
down to us from our primate ancestors. Violence. Maybe who knows.
Question is how ingrained is that stuff? Well, yeah,
I mean if you think that we have inherited something yet,
what can we do about it? Or are we stuck? Or
can we change if we make the right choices?
So we've got for you this hour or three stories
where choice, individual choice challenges, destiny, right?
Maybe we help. Yeah,
I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab stick around
[inaudible]
to get things started, let's just take the question that was just in the air.
Are we human beings violent forever and forever and forever. Amen.
Is that just who we are? That's a good question. It's a good question. Right?
And the people who usually say yes,
we say yes because in part because of our ancestors, we like them.
They're like us. That's how it goes. On the other hand, let me tell you a story.
I was hoping there would be another hair. Yes. Do you remember this guy? Um,
Robert Sapolsky on? Oh yeah, that's Robert Sapolsky.
We've had him on the show a couple times. He's a neuroscientist.
Spends most of the year at Stanford being a lab rat scientist doing neurobiology
in the lab. But in the summers, most summers, um,
I go and spend time in east Africa,
in the Serengeti studying wild baboons there. Why?
What is your, what is he working on?
What's his reason to suppose he's interested in studying stress?
The effect that stress has on the body.
And it turns out baboons are a perfect source of data because they're always
under stress. You know,
the one thing we know about baboons and have known forever is that they fight
baboons constantly. Not just metaphorically,
but literally have been the textbook example of a highly aggressive male
dominated hierarchical society because these animals hunt because they live in
these aggressive troops on the Savannah parentheses,
just like we humans used to invest. We evolved very similarly.
They have a constant baseline level of aggression,
which inevitably spills over into their social lives,
which is why he studied them.
So what's supposed to he does basically is he goes into the bush and he watched
it. Your field notes some,
there's a floor them there and a whole shelf is offices covered with these field
notebooks.
Each one containing detailed notes of who groomed who and who's not getting
along with who and who's messing around with who in the bushes.
He tells the following of a particular moment in his baboons watching,
which completely changed his life,
changed how he sees the world. It happened about 30 years ago.
Spolsky was a young guy just out of Grad school studying his first troop, my,
my first baboons troop. He really loved. These were animals.
I was very connected with the most ways. It was a pretty average group. Yeah,
you're basic bad balloon troop.
The females were highly affiliated with each other. Um,
they had a very stable ranking system. The males, meanwhile,
the highly aggressive dumping on each other cause that's just what males do,
right? Oh, you silly thought.
Mid Eighties, a big boom in tourism in Canada,
wonders for the economy, lots of new lodges, lots of large expansions.
And there happened to be the next territory over the tourist lodge.
And this one particular lodge, he says he'd gotten really big really fast.
And during the time the lodge greatly expanded their garbage dump,
which means basically that they just dug a hole out behind the lodge.
Then each day attractor came out with the leftovers and dumped it there.
So what we're talking about here, if you can nasally imagine,
is he big steaming pile of [inaudible] trash,
half eaten food, baking in the sun,
smell wafting in the breeze from miles and miles and into the nostrils of
baboons everywhere.
So it was not long before a troop of baboons not supposed skis,
but one nearby discovered the garbage and just started feeding on it.
And here where there are eating leftover desserts and chicken whatevers,
all dump full of food must be to a Bevin like,
like venturing into heaven, Manna in the wilderness.
So this troop almost immediately shifted their entire behavior to,
they just slept in the trees above the garbage dump and instead of getting up at
six in the morning to start foraging, uh,
they would waddle down around two minutes of nine and the tractor would show up
at nine o'clock and dump the food and they would have 20 minutes of sheer frenzy
and then they'd go back to sort of being couch potatoes.
And this is how it went for awhile.
So they're over there living off of garbage and somehow some of the males in my
troupe figure this out. These males think we got to get in on this.
We've got to go over there and take their food.
What emerged was each morning a bunch of males would run a kilometer or so a to
the garbage dump and fight their way.
Okay.
Get some of the garbage. So every morning there'd be a showdown basically. Yeah.
And they would come back with canine slashes and stuff like that,
but they'd also have drumsticks, cakes, hamburgers,
and this ritual. Suppose ski went on for years,
year and then a few years into it,
I got word that there were a couple of baboons in this garbage dump troop that
looked awful and something was wrong with them.
Some guys from the lodge had called them and said, hey,
you better get down here and look at this. And when he got there,
what he saw was horrible,
almost with rotting hands walking on their elbows,
just really bad. So trying to figure out what this is about,
get veterinarians involved and we finally figure out his tuberculosis.
Turns out some infected meat had been thrown in the dump and then eaten by the
baboons.
And this was really bad news because while tuberculosis and people is a really
slow moving disease,
he be kills nonhuman primates and weeks and it's a nightmare of a disease for
them. In just a short time, the garbage jump troop was completely decimated.
Not to mention that the tough guys and supposed skis. True.
The ones that had gone to the dump every morning,
they got it to have the same kind of rotting hands and they all die of it.
That must've been really kinda tragic to witness.
And this was not a good period for me.
[inaudible]
no, these were my animals. I had, I had grown up with these guys.
But you know, while Polsky was heartbroken,
now that half of the Alpha males in his troop were dead,
he didn't notice some strange things started to happen.
Mm.
Changes. How do they change? Well, grooming spiked grooming.
So you and I sit on a branch and I take little fleas out of here for, yes. Well,
usually when a female grooms a a male, the males never reciprocate,
but suddenly they were even weirder.
You saw adult male sitting in contact with each other and grooming each other.
You know how, how, how rare that is. B,
like if I'm suddenly in the middle of round five of a heavyweight bout Mike
Tyson just decided to stop boxing and that's all his photo clerk comb Evander
Holyfield's hair.
You'll be like that if you were a bad mood ologist it would have been less
shocking if these guys had wings or were photosynthetic or something up to then
I had seen like 30 seconds of male male grooming in the course of 15 years,
but at the time supposedly kind of wrote it off.
This was just some freak event that wasn't going to last.
So he actually stopped studying even after that big investment of time.
Scientifically they were ruined by such a non-natural event,
removing half the study subjects as scientist.
It became less interesting to you. That was the rationale.
It was just too painful to go and watch these guys.
So I moved to the other end of the reserve
about 40 miles away and started with a new troop there and for six years I would
not go anywhere near this corner of the park is, I just didn't want to be there.
Now fast forward six years and we come to the moment.
That really changed things for him.
Really flipped him into a different way of thinking and it happened kind of by
accident. So about six years later,
I'm out there for the first time with who was soon destined to become my wife
and decided I wanted to kind of show her where I had grown up.
What part of the park you want to go to? The old haunt. Um, yeah, basically.
So went there and the troop was there and they were acting pretty much the same
as before. Lots of grooming, not so much fighting that isn't that nice.
And they're still like this great remnant trooper and he's sitting there with
his wife. He just pointing out all the different baboons on.
There's Tiva and Arizona, I don't know whoever.
And then it hits him this [inaudible] whatever. Wait a second.
There was only one male left. We'd been there at the time of the TB outbreak.
Dawn, don't know. Follow this one meal. Stick with me for just one second.
And you will get the thing about male baboons,
first thing you to understand is around puberty, the males get a little antsy,
they get itchy, they're bored, and they just pick up and leave. So in a troop,
any of the adult males grew up someplace else,
which meant that these new guys that were coming into polsky's troop were coming
in from the outside, from the old world order Jerky,
real dog eat dog world out there. So you got to figure,
these new males are coming in with old expectations that they're going to have
to kick ass to be respected,
which would mean that this whole Koombaya situation should evaporate the moment
these guys show up. But it didn't
[inaudible]
it stuck. Oh my God, the new guys are learning.
We don't do stuff like that here. And if the new guys are learning a new way,
well that means the old way,
the violent way isn't the only way that this,
this Florida
who was one of those moments,
it will be one of the three or four best silence moments of my life.
The key question was how to these guys unlearn their entire childhood culture of
aggression, Blah, blah,
and somehow learned we don't do stuff like that around here. Well,
well what, well, how do they unlearn something that it was supposedly built in?
Um, well he doesn't really know exactly, oh but, but, but,
but here's suppose skis, hunch. Here's this hunch and this is really cool.
I may have to do with that precarious moment when the new guy comes in.
Now normally what happens in this sort of status quo is that the new guy arrives
and it's just a really bad experience for him. It's awful.
I mean you look at them and you just identify with like freshman year in college
or something, they're completely peripheral.
Every male who's higher ranking dumps on them. And even worse,
this freshman math boon is completely ignored by the ladies.
You just sit there and say, somebody groom him. My God,
I went to a sophomore year until somebody groom him. Come on,
why don't they go to them? Well, because if they did,
some adult male would have attacked them. Oh,
so the ladies hang back while he's out there biting and climbing and trying to
scratch his way in. What you've got here is a cycle
[inaudible]
that has existed for a long, long time. But if you make one small change,
just remove the Alpha male. Take him out of the equation.
Suddenly
the females are more relaxed and more likely to take a social gamble of reaching
out to somebody new.
The key thing is the females both ski thinks that it's all about timing.
If the females can get to the new guy early enough,
everything is different. It's remarkable. In your typical troop,
it's three months on the average before the first female grooms you in this true
[inaudible]
six days can out six days as a compared to three months.
Yeah. In a world in which from day one, as an adolescent male,
you're treated better. Something about the aggressiveness melts away.
[inaudible].
The thing though is jab at a, before we get too carried away,
we do have to ask the question just how permanent this change is.
As Nice as it is.
So I explained this whole story that you've just told to a professor at Harvard
named Richard Wrangham, him, his, he's an evolutionary biologist,
studies chimps particularly, so I asked him, well, okay,
you've heard the story about the baboons. What do you think? Yeah, no, it's,
it's a nice example of the potential for some change.
Clearly we should put boundaries on it. You know,
lots of baboons had been started across Africa and this sort of example has
never been found in a natural context.
But I think these guys, wild baboons, they just happened upon a a garbage dump.
Yeah.
It's just not a very natural context to have humans provide food that leads to
several males dying.
But at that means that I could imagine going on a helicopter all over Africa
shooting all the Alpha males and then giving all the ladies a chance to um,
create a different baboon culture and meet at what I guess I'm wondering is do
you think an absurd situation like that that the baboons are,
he might change its essential nature?
I don't think it'll change its essential nature.
I can see that there can be a cultural influence that may last a little bit of
time,
but the larger influence clearly is the set of,
of genes that produce a particular kind of brain of a boon is basically a baboon
until you get some kind of genetic change.
And that is something that supposedly has not seen though. So professor, yeah.
Once a genetic change to make sure that this is really real permanent and yeah,
but it's, but here's the thing.
I don't know if this constitutes a genetic change, but it has been 20 years.
Yes. 20 years. And suppose skis,
original baboons troop is still operating in this peaceful mode,
even though dozens of new males have come and gone at this point.
And the idea that something that was thought to be so unchangeable could change
and change quickly and then stay changed as a result of something so airy and
undefinable is culture will that has caused Robert Spolsky dare I say it to
hope. Absolutely. In, it's not something that I do by, by nature.
Not a hopeful guy by nature. But no, not at all. In fact,
this story got him so hopeful.
He decided to send it to Foreign Affairs magazine,
which is a magazine read by a lot of politicians. Yeah. Um,
and they went forward and so we had to ask him after it was published.
Did anyone write you back? Um,
no. Basically not. I basically heard nothing from anyone. No.
From anyone. Yes. Big Yawning. Silence. I, I,
I'm sure George Bush and Cheney read it each evening and tremble at its
implications. But no, basically, as far as I can tell,
it was a huge waste of time for me to write it. Ah, well when you read it,
yeah. Thanks. My Mother didn't even [inaudible] radio.
That will continue in a moment.